hey everyone it's Valentine's Day I
don't know why decide you're going to be
attaching to go live pleasant today is
action Valentine's Day and one of the
things that I surprising it with was I
was going to cook dinner yeah you're
Nina so excited about this so we went
the whole foods whole bottle a bunch of
stuff and she didn't want peanut butter
and honey sandwiches for dinner so this
video is Evan making dinner yes now if
you want regal videos about how to cook
you can check out it all the videos that
Nina has done I'm cooking so this is my
group first thing we need to wash your
hands this is all I've known as I'm
doing and then one's going to buy so I'm
gonna pull off some stuff here's why I
started with this is key boosters
they're on sale at whole foods and you
eat them raw so the zero preparation
except for adding lemon which is awesome
so we bought 10 okay so i decided to
make stir-fried this is how to make stir
fry every time you've got mushrooms
tomatoes ground beef the magic
ingredient what it is called it's
nothing snow peas over sri lanka make
rice onion red onion
cut I guess we gotta wash stuff we need
washing music you can see when the moon
hits your eye like a big pizza pie
that's amore bells will ring
ting-a-ling-a-ling ting-a-ling-a-ling
and will say he Tubba that means nice
life beautiful life hearts will play
tippy did you take if you can beat a
like get out of kind of love when this
is the dramatic finish school is that
Toby's not happy cubby tell me school's
out me but you see back in all that body
that's amore best cooking video ever
zero instruction washed everything okay
spices the key for me is the time do you
like time it's okay it's okay you didn't
sound like you're too excited about them
by secret ingredient there's no longer
time let's see oregano a little bit why
not salt pepper rosemary little rosemary
smoking stampede spice mix
sketchy but maybe we'll try a little bit
basil ok that's it look good so let's
see we gonna walk you need a walk can't
you off the top there's a lot we go so
first I'm going to zoo and then get some
pool oil I don't even know how much I'm
just pouring it what up now when you're
making stuff ok that's the official term
making stuff you're supposed to cook it
in the order of what takes longest the
code first and then slowly add more
things in my challenge is I have no idea
what take so long that i have so i'm
gonna i'm going to make a guess rice we
can microwave I gotta decide to clean
onion meet peas tomatoes and mushrooms
the order that i am decided the going is
as follows
the mushrooms the mushrooms are first
mushroom and onion then snow peas then
tomatoes oh my god here it goes the
tomatoes I need to wash this again so
it's very important when you're buying
Tomatoes with the vine attack that you
don't lift it from the vine or they can
go fly I learned that lesson today okay
what I say mushrooms onion snow peas
tomatoes and then the beef is going to
class that's you okay we gotta chop just
give visual cutting board look at how
many nice people this is crazy I'm going
to go with this one and feel like this
is the right decision Oh any garlic I
will just remind that the block is I
we're going to do this quickly you know
what your ripple mushrooms that's how we
do it this is stir fry style okay rip
you know what I'm just going to bring it
all over there yes chop it up like this
for all about efficiency ppl.z proper
technique is you take a mushroom and rip
it on top of the same we got speed we
got delicious the but it takes too long
you're not going to do
that's right have a logical questions
did that really happen to you aspiring
by now I have Zero nutritional
information to share with you about
anything that 50 today except that i'm
putting that kind of mushrooms in here
and i hope it works out now it's going
to get really wiry as mushrooms leak
sweat me whatever doesn't matter darling
darling we buy a chopped garlic from
Moscow let me make a face blue ball just
smash it on top of that one pakmar smash
mix it all up and we're done with that
hey onion with an onion I cut off one
side and then I cut off the other side
push the way we'll clean it up later
right the good thing is you don't the
person who doesn't cook is one cleans
right now okay so I'm just take a shot
get away from the crime this is one real
technique here just pushing it back down
that's all keeping your head back to
avoid the tears the only tears should be
crying about yummy this food is at the
end this one it's so amazing okay that's
all done look at that pop that in here
a certified block spoon right here yeah
there you go with work on live action
now live action right here I'm actually
with Nina here let's do it let's do a
selfie let's do so break down swing that
whoa okay live action here it is here oh
oh oh so it's very important it's very
important when you're cooking with a wok
that's metal not to touch the edge
because you can burn yourself mix it up
I feel like I want to add some soy sauce
or something to this but we're having a
whole bunch of other stuff dude well soy
sauce mix with basil that's the question
I feel like we should where's the soy
sauce yeah we buy soy sauce friends yet
will let the mushroom marinade there and
okay just throw it on top picks it up
mmm yeah that is some yummy Valentine's
Day dinner okay what's next snow peas
snow peas I still like them crunchy I
don't like when they get to I don't know
I don't like I don't like cooked
vegetables green peppers snow peas you
know like I like the crunch so we watch
them then that's why it's not we just go
min I kind of made a mess here cut that
made a mess it's okay Nina just clean
this this morning so it's all clean now
we have your snow peas that's looking
good nice looking solid and then we need
out Tomatoes we're getting close I'm
just going to cut them into into chunks
slices slices here and then like I want
a bit shocked right about this size
that's what I'm that's
for it here oh yeah tomato I put my hand
on your tomato when you tomato me to
beta that's the remix okay important to
lick your fingers and then you throw it
into the into the wok yeah this is
sexiness in a walk right here that's
sexy time now don't know what to do this
doesn't look cooked enough Oh gotta ask
the season ain't France I'll wait wait
wait for the meat for the seasoning the
meat usually cooks pretty quick so I got
to let this sit for a while I don't know
how long as a guidance for you guys but
let it till it's done what I'm waiting
for really is i want the mushrooms to be
cooked when the mushrooms are good yeah
this again me mushroom I'm ready to put
the meat in now if you want to be you
know really nice and valentine's day
instead of letting your Valentine clean
up while you're waiting for this to
happen do these fools out here Nina's
happy that
okay what else put Tomatoes secrets away
then then the job of cleanup at the end
will be as this and we kissed what you
know what's it pretty simple friends we
did a towel here come here this is Tom
look here perfect let's try to mushroom
Beulah yeah so rice let's go put the
microwave
44 minutes and then you have to pay
attention to presentation it's critical
valentine's day and oysters
I was commercially on the place that are
putting
that's okay Nina is always concerned
about the cleanliness and New Canaan is
Valentine's it's okay I'm taking over
here just type operate the camera and
then enjoy the food and cry over how
great it is let's get back here and do
some mixing mix that up solid okay put
this back down oh I'll be right back
because presentation is important
Kenneth
sup your kiss is that too close who
cares okay walk around this is cooking
up guys let's try another mushroom rice
is I'm all done get that kiss get some
glasses very hot I'm really feeling like
four minutes with a good college hot mix
it up some more okay we're gonna ask
Anna beef in I don't know I just a gut
feeling I'm feeling like that was the
right time I got no guidance pues the
way to do this but I'm feeling it so
we're open up this extra lean grass-fed
pasture-raised a product of the United
States there it is one pound and dumb oh
all right mix it up Oh can't touch you
switch my club look love mix that up mmm
yeah time to season friends season it we
got smoking stampede hume spice mix not
too much of that stuff cuz i believe i
would it's like oh baby to milepost or
whatever I said that may be too much and
I added my third well I wanted to oh my
nose is burning I was drool the less at
them okay swallow okay rosemary
Oh Mary Ruth okay soft the dirty soy
sauce I'm not going to put a lot of salt
n is 3 twirls what is that cloud ago
let's do five two three four five six
pepper basil whoa basil and oregano God
still loves oregano man this is just a
mix of stuff bring the camera let's look
at this good then you see it can you see
all the stuff on top yeah throw it all
in there however face it don't matter we
can hot man i'm in a sweater holy cow
now many drinks oh I should add some
alcohol to that but soy sauce and why
many time no no where's the wine in the
water and cabinet your red wine in the
fridge p oh can I see can I say cannot
see Oh Matthew but like this one okay
mean Alexis wine so that's why I chose
it on purpose this magazines of vintage
2004 red wine corkscrew corkscrews move
yeah corkscrew Rico the cooks commands
really happy
wire
listen it's organized chaos I have no
idea what I'm doing but it's coming
along you know what the the peas are
starting to get flimsy which I don't
like so I think we're gonna prepare the
meat looks okay look look it's not raw
good mushrooms ah yummy go he's a little
bit too much water in here for my liking
but will just drain it as I put on the
plate I'm going to turn this off I'm
going to get some rice on the plate like
a spoonful of rice put that smoosh it
down nice oh I didn't do the avocado
okay now I mean the rush put it into the
avocado and I'm kind of freaking out
okay my wife had a great video on how to
do home kados oh my god oh oh that is
nasty I'm throwing that away we don't
get no avocado see what I wanted to do
with slice it and just put a little on
the side a presentation and just a
little extra done but anybody got time
for that do you nobody got time inviting
have time anybody got time for that so
as I bring it out I just want to drain
it it's not too wet on the plate monster
Nina you're really hungry very hungry
very hungry this is it okay we set it
down and this is one spectacular
Valentine's Day dinner let me go get
Nina hi Nina how are you will you will
you be my Valentine
yeah okay well I've made a special
surprise for you you have to close your
eyes though yeah well what here's what
you can do you just hope that will be
there you go we can't let me walk you
here hold my hand okay you can open your
eyes now Yeah right sit down that's your
seat you got the alcohol bottle right
next to you okay this is the moment of
truth happy Valentine's Day dinner
Nina's gonna dig in get some goodness
make sure to grab a mushroom with that
and what she wanted to be thing you
gotta get some meat in there too
everything is it really good yes I fry
that's amazing I was going with it was a
thought that counts but the food is
actually good let me try one hold on
whoa mmm tomatoes milk tomato fresh
tomatoes in there Nina's eating it's
always important to have the camera on
somebody while they're eating so oh that
was great mmm mmm hello so we're gonna
enjoy a Valentine's Day dinner guys that
was pretty easy right you can do this
you could tell you I could do it you
could do it if you want me or needed to
make something else leave comment
believe subscribe almost see you see hey
thank you for watching okay there's no
towel to drive stop they're leaking
I'm gonna be nice or quinoa so we have
the rice cooker yeah I use it do you
want me to show you know Nina is doing
some sexy dance in behind the camera
it's distracting me my job if you saw my
face I was like why I didn't do anything
yeah um sorry one second why should I
make a suggestion no we need the cartoon
play for you a necessary coming action
Oh cooking his hard work Nina ate the
entire plate and had more than half the
oysters are you feeling I didn't know I
stress i bought the other part i lu two
three hey mr. cars make a yummy whole
plate mm-hmm